of course las vegas has some of the best
restaurants in the world and
representing one of those today is
michelin star chef sean herrgate owner
of the caviar bar thanks for being here
today that's a pleasure tell us about
the caviar bar where it is how long you
guys have been around well it's about a
little bit over eight months old uh
we're at the resorts world hotel uh
which is actually they're a year open
now so it's gone very quick yeah um you
know great success it's been a very good
response for the caviar bar and i'm
excited for you to come yeah
the buzz is really good i hear it's
awesome and today you have a sample of
what you guys are doing there well you
know we've opened brunch couple weeks
ago so we're really trying to promote
the brunch and i think something that's
so comforting and it's also very healthy
and also familiar right avocado toast so
what we got is a little house avocado
we're gonna mash it up
you're gonna mash it up with me i will
match you can do this right all right
well can you have any openings there we
go
we're gonna get avocado mashings here a
little bit of lime juice okay how
difficult is it to find good avocados
now ah they're everywhere okay they're
everywhere and it's also a good season
too summer is always the best for uh
avocados okay
all right a little bit of salt
that's good a little bit of pepper now
we're going to put the toast on the
plate everyone knows what toast is right
yeah yeah
there we go so
you can do this at home and i think
obviously it's a bit of a trend right
everyone who wants to be healthy eats
avocado toast right
it's making sure that you just buy the
best products so when you eat it
it's obviously healthy for you right
that's what we want to do yeah
absolutely
all of this stuff is just fluff you
could eat it just like this we're going
to put a little bit of pimento espelled
on top to give it some spice
then we've got this alaskan king crab
you could put oh wow any sort of thing
on top if you like if you want piquito
crab if you want to put shrimp on top
whatever makes you happy
and this is a part of the brunch menu
this is part of the brunch menu a little
bit of chopped chives a little bit of
chopped herbs goes on top
nice presentation too yeah it's going to
be fun right yeah have a good time
uh it's also colorful and i think it
represents great seasonality and also
the quality of what you're eating caviar
bar inside resorts world great brunch
offerings every day of the week
uh we actually are open seven days a
week uh just for dinner but we do brunch
on sunday sunday brunch all right thanks
so much for being here sean appreciate
it pleasure we'll be right back